how have you actually been telling your
friends and family about this movie and
what it's about because i think this is
one of those the less you know about the
second and third act the better i've
just been saying it's about love
and food
two things we need to survive
in the world yeah something similar i've
just sort of been saying i guess it's
sort of you know a girl meets boy um
thriller that's kind of one way of going
going about it yeah it's definitely a
hard one to describe a girl meets a boy
and then never leaves
what was it like though when you guys
got the script because did your agents
or managers or people involved tell you
what was going to happen or did they say
you just need to read this
mine just said you just need to read
this they kind of gave me a little
warning they were like it gets quite
dark that but that was sort of all they
gave me um
so yeah it was i kind of came to it the
way you did which is i i think the best
way and reading it i was just like what
like
you know every time you think you know
what's happening um it takes such a
twist and turn you know i'd met with
mary parent earlier about six months
before we started and then she kind of
gave me an idea she didn't say anything
about what he actually did
um but i had a bit of an idea and then
and then when i was reading it i went in
there with all these expectations and
then for the beginning of the movie i
keep getting all these funny moments and
this banter and interaction and then i'm
kind of like okay like i'm waiting for
the other shoe to drop and then when it
finally does it still caught me by a
surprise even though i knew
to expect something so we hope people
will feel that same
drop as we did i guess oh a hundred
percent um have you guys seen the movie
ex machina
for not an incredible movie i'm going
somewhere i'm going somewhere with this
so ex machina is one of my favorite bits
in that movie is the dance scene oscar
with everyone dancing and i judge every
movie after that has a dance scene
against ex machina so i'm just curious
when you guys were dancing in this did
you feel that pressure we need to beat
oscar i'm joking around but you know i
know we both love that song oh yeah
night yeah yeah
such
saturday
but but mimi had this idea of us kind of
at the end of the movie sort of getting
synchronized
in this dance thing and and i remember
we we had both been so worried about
kind of keeping
the the movie and the characters as
grounded as possible it's like how could
how could we get to that moment
but i have to say
we we had rehearsals and then kind of
it's just sort of found its way there
the thing is like i would imagine i
don't know this but are you more nervous
to film something where you're dancing
than even some of the harder camera
moves just because dancing is like you
know you're it's i could never do the
dancing
yeah yeah i mean we one of our second no
our second day filming together was the
dancing on that like second day
that was so fun
yeah you know the one with because that
was all kind of improvised and it was
sort of us looking at each other being
like what's your move that's where the
hip thrust
came out and it's like i'm like oh i
just know how to do the shoulders you're
good at the shot that's your that's your
little thing but but the one at the end
needs to be you know focused and
determined but and that was nice because
it was a bit more choreographed so you
know me me our director had a has a
background in dance so she had a very
specific idea of what she wanted and so
that was sort of quite nice because we
felt safe and like i guess i'll just
i'll do these moves and hope they they
look good something that also is really
cool about the film is you have these
really upbeat 80s songs playing against
really really dark stuff and it's like
it the film does such a great job with
tone and being able to balance these
things can you sort of talk about
i guess the the music and also it's
bright lit scenes with really [ __ ] up
stuff sorry for my language
yeah it was it was that was in the
script and and it was something that
kind of intrigued me about the character
because i i saw that as an opportunity
in a way
to to for us to sort of see something
very different than what we what we've
been seeing about him to that point in
the movie
and just him in these private moments
kind of dancing by himself were so
they were funny but like they were weird
and also kind of revealing about who he
was or he might have been in a way so i
thought that was just a very um
different way of telling backstory
about a character um and then
of course there was the one on the
on the operating table i love it when
when films do that because
you find yourself laughing or you find
yourself
enjoying something and then it's almost
like you feel guilty about it because
you realize what you're watching like it
really does like that kind of tone like
i find so enjoyable because yeah it
you're it makes you feel all the more
uncomfortable weirdly because
you shouldn't really be enjoying
what you're watching because it's so
dark and so it kind of yeah it means
that you're always feeling slightly
unsettled which i think is really good
one of the other things about this film
is and i can't believe i'm going to say
this but it actually it's it's
far-fetched but it's not that
far-fetched i actually think the
disturbing part is this could be
happening um
i mean maybe i'm reaching on this but
it's just uh did you guys even think
about that or am i really reaching with
this
well you have jeffrey dahmer right who
who really did
eat his victims i mean
and um so and and that was one of the
things that i was
sort of dead set on is i i wanted to go
back and kind of look at every serial
killer in the last three decades i mean
you know ted bundy then you have like
the green river one and i mean and it's
terrifying because like you realize how
many of these people how many of these
serial killers hunted women for the last
like three four decades like all going
back to the 60s and so it's just
so it's it's
and
yeah so it's not
unheard of i gotta rap but just real
fast anything that you think soon to be
fans of the movie would be surprised to
learn about the actual making of the
film noah's
pink dress
um
was
steamed every single day oh it was and
and we were saying but they're in a
fight
now
and
still still it was steamy
but i'm just i'm only saying that
because i think
i don't we were always looking at each
other with mimi and going like i wonder
if this is going to become like a weird
iconic halloween costume or something
one day because you know the the pink
dress and it kind of does
have that aura about it like
other older movies that we've seen you
know when you kind of recognize
so yeah and you with the eye like the
eye coming out the bulging eye holding
iron sebastian having to go that's a
pretty strong hit
like i thought it was just a and then
they're like no she hit you with a meat
grinder i'd say
it would do some damage
okay
uh yeah i was like terrified my eye
would never like come back
keep having me stuck by
i got to stop there but i really mean it
congrats on the movie you guys did such
a great job
thank you good to see you thanks have a
great day
you